what's going on guys this is Rob and if
you're enjoying the content here on my
channel then make sure you hit the like
button and make sure you hit subscribe
so you can't decide what direction the
content on my channel goes in in the
foreseeable future
okay so we are getting into Action
Comics revenge and one of the things
that you guys probably noticed when we
covered the Suicide Squad rebirth spree
lude to this is that I didn't really go
in depth into hank henshaw
and the reason why is because I wanted
to offer that explanation in this video
because it seemed to make the most sense
to get this video actually covers or at
least this video will cover sort of the
origin DC will kind of skim over it will
go a little more in depth than DC is
doing in this particular story though
offer more of an origin of his character
and why it is that his memories are
restored because normally they shouldn't
be so with regards to Action Comics
revenge the first part of this and I'll
mention once we get past it the first
part of this actually takes place before
the events of the Suicide Squad rebirth
story initially remember cyborg superman
had basically been traveling around and
just recruiting various people of
various enemies of Superman into his
cost what was so ironic about this is
that cyborg superman was recruiting
enemies that historically were enemies
of Superman which is to say they were
some of his most notable foes back
before the new 52 and that's why I
always struck people it's kind of weird
when this first cropped up because
either it was DC trying to hit home or
it was intentional and so the idea is
that we initially pick up with the
character of manga I guess this is
really like the son of Mongol -
that's what you want to call him but
nonetheless you know he was always one
of Superman's most notable enemies due
to its strength agility so on and so
forth and was always looking for a way
to defeat Superman now on the surface
we're initially given this idea that
Mongols successfully killed Superman
only for us to find out the Mongol is
basically trapped inside of his own
black mercy plants now remember this
goes back to the Trinity rebirth the
very first story that we did and I'll
include that the Superman playlist as
well just so you guys have a
well-rounded idea of everything that's
going into this but this goes into the
Trinity rebirth story when it covered
Batman Superman and Wonder Woman coming
together and discovering the whole idea
of the black mercy plant being used by
poison ivy and so on and so forth as
well as Mongol himself now the black
mercy plant under normal circumstances
anyway the black mercy plant when it's
bonded to a person basically puts them
in this sort of idyllic dream state in
the sense that they basically live out
the greatest dreams that they could ever
have the greatest fantasies they could
ever imagine for mongol it's killing
Superman at this point of course we end
up finding out that Eradicator is there
at eradicating
recruiting Mongol to their cause but
then we also end up joining Lois Lane
and Superman now one of the things to
remember and one of the things that
people tend to forget is that because of
the events of Superman reborn and Mister
Mixel piddle it kind of messing around
with everything and warping reality and
so on and so forth
what DC did with rebirth is this when
the new 52 first launched DC basically
came around and said okay we want you
guys to imagine that we've never written
a Superman story before these characters
are all appearing for the very first
time right wrong or otherwise it had
great reactions that had mixed reactions
what DC rebirth came back and did and
what Superman reborn came back and did
is it said okay what we're going to do
is we're basically going to have mr.
Mixel pedelec in the events of Superman
reborn mess with all reality screw
everything up and what he's going to do
is he's going to take the new 52
universe in the classic DC Universe
which is basically everything before the
new 52 after crisis on Infinite Earths
in 1985 and merge them into one and so
characters are going to get new origin
stories and so on and so forth and so
what DC is asking us to do right now at
the moment when we're reading DC rebirth
it's a basically just imagine that the
characters that have new origins those
are definitively their new origins
that's their new histories characters
that do not have new origins basically
have the same stories they did before
you know when the new 52 first kicked
off that's basically what they're asking
us to do in the case of Superman
what DC is saying right now in DC
rebirth in this moment is that there
never was a new 52 Superman that it's
always just been this Superman that's
just the way it is it's always just been
this one guy and that exists in relation
to him only and that's why comets can be
a little bit confusing because what we
end up doing here is we switch over to
Hank Henshaw and the reason why we do
this is because of the fact that this
whole thing about hank henshaw basically
deals with the idea of him transforming
him becoming cyborg superman the reason
why this happened is because of the fact
that remember in DC rebirth hank henshaw
was effectively introduced for the very
first time as the Hinshaw that we know
and the result is that when mr. Mixel
pedelec started screwing with everything
messing with all reality and so on and
so forth what we found out is that hank
henshaw memories of the classic DC
Universe were restored and so for those
of you guys who have been reading DC
Comics for a long time this hank henshaw
remembers the events of like Sinestro
Corps war
members the reign of the Superman he
remembers destroying her city he
remembers all those things and again
that's the nature of DC rebirth for
those of you guys who were new that's
the nature of it all classic DC is
becoming just as important as the new 52
now because there are elements that DC's
grabbing from before the new 52 and
rolling them in this is another example
this also hits home at the idea that
like for example Hank Henshaw
talking to Margo says hey remember when
we destroyed Co City has his
memories from before the new 52 happened
that's the way that all this stuff
unfolds now what DC is also asking us to
believe here is that hank henshaw
when he was appearing as a human he
always just appeared as a human for
whatever reason he just had this sort of
human shell so to speak over his face we
already started to do when he basically
had his memories restored during the
events of Superman reborn as it he went
out and he grabbed this oblivion stone
this stone that when its merged with
this other half allows its user to
basically modify their body any way they
choose and the result is that widows
memories restored combined with grabbing
this oblivion stone Hank Henshaw
officially transformed himself into
cyborgs Superman that's how he comes
back that's why all this stuff is really
kind of crazy and it's really kind of
weird because it's almost like the new
52 is suffering from a case of amnesia
right like the new 52 happened and
suddenly DC forgot everything before the
new 52 took place DC rebirth are like
the memories being restored basically
that's the best example I can give you
with regards to how all this is coming
together so a lot of stuff with regards
to cyborg superman we're covering a good
portion of that in like Sinestro Corps
war in our Green Lantern run on Sunday
so again that really kind of feeds into
a lot of these these older stories and
different things along those lines but
the long and short of this you know like
we said in the last video a cyborg
Superman's probably the most notable
enemy of Superman himself of course
cyborg superman rose to prominence
during the events of reign of the
Superman when the original Superman died
and then Superboy and steel and
Eradicator and cyborg superman rose up
and we're all basically laying claim to
the mantle of superman as bad as that
story was but that's really where he
became the most famous or at least where
he really rose to prominence now of
course this basically reveals to us that
again cyborg had been the one traveling
around and recruiting all these
different people metallo blank
Eradicator Mongul
so on and so forth that's really just
the nature of what he's doing at the
moment and it all exists for the purpose
of just trying to defeat Superman now to
talk a little bit more about why it is
that cyborg wants to defeat Superman in
the first place again this all goes back
to his old story so it all goes back to
the reign of the Superman with cyborg
with with Hank Henshaw
he was really more of like a play on the
Fantastic Four is really what it was Lex
Corp Lex Luthor funded a trip to send
some astronauts into space to experiment
with cosmic radiation two of them were
killed Hank Henshaw and his wife came
back they eventually began to succumb to
their powers hank henshaw developed the
ability to merge with machinery his wife
was effectively gone forever and then
because this coincided with Superman
fighting the Eradicator prior to his own
death at the hands of doomsday when
Superman threw the Eradicator into the
Sun cyborg came to believe that the
Eradicator being thrown into the Sun by
Superman is what created a solar flare
in the first place making Hank Henshaw
into cyborg superman in the first place
that's the old-school 1990s origin of
cyborg and that's how his character
always progressed again this grabs that
stuff and it brings it back now at this
point we start to jump into the events
of Suicide Squad rebirth which is the
saying what Superman was doing around
the time that event was happening and
what we end up finding out is that when
Zod was you know basically got the bomb
out of his head and when he started
going awry and so on and so forth again
that videos down in the description this
led to Superman kind of investigating
the area as well as Batman trying to
figure out what was going on now of
course with Superman tracking down a
radical reef prison alongside cyborg can
recruit General Zod Superman immediately
responded now the way this is done is
actually pretty intelligent and it's
actually pretty cool
initially Batman tries to intervene
Batman says hey look man like yeah I can
help you out if you need me to I can get
involved
Superman says no this is a Kryptonian
problem I will handle it now the funny
thing about this is that it's also
dealing with a slight bit of hubris on
behalf of Superman and that never
happens Superman never usually gets
arrogant and in truth it's just the way
we're looking at it he's not like all
I'm Superman I'm going to take out a
radical and cyborg and you know they're
not going to be me because I'm Superman
that's not really the mindset here but
remember Superman's fought these guys
before he fought over a Decatur back in
the 1990s he fought cyborg back in the
1990s they're not new to
him he's not unsure of what they're
about he knows perfectly well what their
capabilities are and how to deal with
them and so of course what this does is
it also coincides of the arrival of
cyborgs and Eradicator entering the
black vault and were to figure out what
in the world is going on now of course
again this gives us the impact of the
black vault in terms of how it all works
in the sense that the Phantom Zone
forces people to basically wrestle with
their fears and the things that torment
their minds over and over and over again
and to deal with it endlessly and that
explains a reason behind why it is that
General Zod basically was insane when he
first emerged from the black vault
because he had spent years and years and
years and years forced to just
experience his worst nightmares time and
time again now of course with Superman
tracking down a radicand cyborg once he
enters a black vault he immediately
begins to experience everything that's
going on inside the black vault the
death of his parents the idea that he
feels like he failed and that's why this
is so cool because this gives us insight
into the mind of Superman it doesn't
mean we get very often I mean we get
insight into his mind insofar as when
he's dealing with Lois Lane or Jonathan
or he's teaching Jonathan had to be a
hero and this Superman feels like a
catastrophic failure in every sense of
the way because of the things that he
could potentially lose and notice this
this is kind of a cool thing because we
could easily juxtapose this to injustice
we could take the injustice line of
stories and say well what if Lois Lane
did die would it really be that
unreasonable for Superman to respond by
just imposing this worldwide
dictatorship is it really that far out
of his character what you're seeing
stories and where you're seeing things
like this where he's forced to face azan
fears and he believes that he failed
because you know Jonathan and Martha
Kent are dead he believes that he failed
because Lois Lane might die because
Jonathan might died because his friends
and family may end up being killed by
the various villains that he's forced to
face off against now of course this also
leads to you know this idea that
Superman struggles with his own inner
demons following this and his ability to
escape the black ball once it's
destroyed during the events that we saw
and Suicide Squad rebirth one of the
things that Superman is not aware of is
that General Zod was there and that
General Zod had made his escape before
the events of Suicide Squad rebirth the
last time we saw General Zod he was
alongside stay or you know really his
girl for the most part and they had
faced off against Superman
and Wonder Woman in the Superman Wonder
Woman comics but that was it I mean they
were basically defeated they were
reimprisonment Phantom Zone and we never
found out what happened to them after
that this picks up following those
events we're just kind of left to
believe that the Suicide Squad more or
less free General Zod accidentally which
sets us at the current moment the
problem with this and something that I
hope you notice here is that Superman
for the most part after coming to with
the destruction of the black vault is
relying largely on this here I can hear
where they're going I can pick up their
distinct sound so on and so forth the
mechanics he's largely talking about how
he hears things course he tracks down
Zod and Eradicator and cyborg he faces
off against him as best he can but the
other cool thing about this is that the
rest of the Superman family is watching
Supergirl
superwoman Lex Luthor is watching the
events unfold whether it's on the news
whether they're hearing that whatever
the case may be all these members of the
Superman family are watching this happen
and that's the important thing about
this and that's why this is so cool one
thing to keep in mind is that no matter
how many versions of Superman exists out
there in the DC Universe there's only
ever one Superman and he's the guy they
all rally around now the result of this
is that in the middle of this fight
Superman basically just takes off then
the reason for this is because of the
fact that once Lois Lane and Jonathan
Kent get to where Superman is supposed
to be or the very least they get back
home to the Kent farm and Superman meets
up with them we end up finding out that
during his escape from the black vault
during the explosion of the black ball
and his exposure to it Superman has
effectively gone blind that being said
guys we're going to go ahead and bring
this video to an end this is the first
part of Action Comics revenge
the next part deals with the Superman
family are coming together to face off
against the Man of Steel but I'm pretty
excited about it it's a pretty solid
story like it's pretty cool anyway guys
if you are new here to comment explain
to make sure you guys to the sub button
to become part of the Rob core you guys
enjoyed this video
make sure you drop a like and yeah I
will catch you all later peace
[Music]